oh my huzzah
the high levels in the father
you're basically saying now this is from
God yes yes okay this is what you've
claimed yeah what I think what God has
saved operator has clean okay
now do you believe this book is from God
yes I do
okay now do you believe the Quran is
from but the cross is not from God it's
not from God
okay oh the issue I contacted is this if
you claim that this Bible is from God it
needs to out would like go through some
certain things criteria to claim those
from God so would you say this book has
arisen it no that's what the Word of God
has no errors it was a Word of God is
rightly divided and inspired Word of God
in the second Timothy chapter 3 verse 15
16 and 17 verse okay I hundred percent
agree with you accepted Timothy that the
Word of God would ever have any
contradictions the Koran and the Bible
I'm talking about know the Word of God
will not have any contradictions the
Word of God would have any verses it I
didn't know taken out no I would not
have any verses taken here okay can we
put these to the test with the Quran and
Bible yes if you want to yes okay can we
often join seven five three please I
know the Quran for if you so can help
each other on the scooter we did
there's a 53:52 okay okay there is okay
now do you know that this verse has been
added in later and I know in the old
manuscripts which verse John 753 to 811
the ways a verse that that's not
something look John 53 and everyone went
to his own house to 811 yeah in most of
the Bible's it will have a footnote
saying you say to you that these verses
are not in the old manuscripts was you
aware of that are you saying basically
you're saying about the woman who was
commit adultery yes I think that's in
mark 16 verse 9 to 20 but this is John
753 where it says these verses have been
added in yes now this is clear-cut most
people know this maybe you're not aware
you can go home and do your research
here is there any verse additional taken
out in the hold on
yes you have any show me please in the
quran in surah bakra chapter 2 verse 109
okay okay can you believe yeah okay
leaving what you're the word the word of
Kalam Allah says okay remember we must
go what not a matter of opinion or what
people think knocking oh by the way
great words of God okay can you show me
where in the footnote that it says to us
Muslims in al-quran that these verses
have been added in they will know in the
old manuscripts
okay verse
again
all right yes sorry okay yeah okay okay
whatever a verse revelation do we
abrogate or cause to be forgotten we
bring a better one similar to it I know
you not that Allah is able in Allah
Allah Felisha in oh dear
okay he has power to do all things okay
so this is yes in the quran surah bakra
chapter 2 106 I was looking for okay
there was crafty it is the law of
abrogation which you have in your own
also in the Quran in surah turn the hell
chapter 16 I believe is I had 101 or 101
talks about if this Quran o Muhammad if
it has any areas of vocation they will
call you I'll mock stood a liar and a
forger so that's two evidence within the
Quran showing there is an abrogation
within the Quran itself and also that
Muhammad is called a must've min Arabic
a forger and a liar because if he
causing the pig and Arabs are asking
what book has what have you or why he
come to show us okay and he said if you
believe yes you know an obligation is so
guys as you can see our dear friend has
brought up the matter of application but
what he is failing to understand is that
I'm saying these verses added in and
taken out and this has been confirmed by
the highest by the Christian scholars of
the highest denominations which have
accepted this that these verses have
been added and taken out now what he's
saying is that the same has happened in
the Quran with abrogation I'm like no
there's a difference and let me tell you
how in the Quran there is free types of
abrogation the first one is the wording
is still in the Quran but the meaning is
not there anymore the second one is that
the meanings to exist but the wording
has been taken out now the third one is
both the meaning and the wording has
been taken out by who not by men not by
the Prophet peace be upon him but by the
author which is God Almighty Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala he is the one that's
taking it pretty words in and taking out
as he knows best
so the difference with the Quran and the
Bible is this because with the Bible is
men men are coming and changing as they
stood and then as they please but here
is the author that's actually changing
it so this is what the difference is and
this is what our friend is not
understanding so if I would do this
little short clip without inserting near
insert in the video which will clarify
the matter and make you guys understand
and ensure the viewers to understand
better so let's carry on with the debate
inshaallah abrogation means to is being
taken out so non-aligned why for example
you know alcohol you know first thing we
say don't come to pray are drunk yeah
then it was totally dismissed yet I'm
asking you very simply and very clearly
and I'm sorry if I didn't make it clear
that a verse has been added in or taken
out like you can come and say to me look
this verse in surah Noor chapter 24
verse 2 has actually been added in and
it's been found by your scholars your
Muslim scholars has been not dating the
old manuscripts and I will put my hands
up and say you know what you're right
but right now what you're doing is that
you're giving me a tough deal of the
Quran I'm asking you I'm asking you what
has been added in and what has been
taken out the way I showed you in your
Bible this Bible John 7 5 3 2 8 11 and
mark 16 verse 9 to 20 has been clearly
by your Christian scholars of the
highest denomination this verses have
been added in I'm asking the same from
you nothing else all right well we must
remember I will say to you I am I am a
seventh-day adventists okay I'm
difference between the other Christians
they will not follow what God has sent
down so that is their protector petition
like you have Sunni Shia okay and
scholars or in your sect okay so as I'm
saying the Word of God is inspired Word
of God which is cannot be changed cannot
be corrupted God has given us perfect
laws favored status paper judgments and
organs and everything within scripture I
respect about what I'm saying is you're
talking about Sunni Shia and maybe
whatever here I'm asking you now vide
about Christians and Christians they
talk about Christians but I ask you no
no no no but I'm not I don't know what
I'm saying to you
look look beat these people who have
gone and checked yes these we're not
talking about these except the cameras
they find their cam what I'm saying to
you is this I'm not talking about six
I've euros you'll save any event is yet
there's the other place
the Catholic yes all in all it's not
it's not like Catholics to say no the
verse has been added in and then your
community no it's not been added in I'm
saying people who know the manuscript
are saying they know their man we've
looked the same we looked but John 753
is not there so we have to let and
inform the Christians that these verses
are added in it doesn't matter if you're
protesting Catholic whatever you believe
it doesn't matter the issue is they are
telling we have checked non history
check the manuscripts and we can't find
these verses however on these on the new
the new Bibles that you have is there so
they have decided to inform you and all
of us with many Bibles that it says
these verses have been added in now you
couldn't do the same with Iran you
couldn't write do we have millions of
people that know the Koran by heart some
understand some doesn't understand but
do we have millions of people that know
the Quran by heart
little kids yes you do you do okay I
want to give you an analogy if you know
the timetable by heart yeah three times
three ten times ten twelve times twelve
yeah my friend over here comes assist
you 3 times 3 is 75 is that so is that
right what's three times three nine nine
yet so if there's ten of us and we know
the timetable by heart do we correct him
yes you would if we correct him can
anybody come and change the Quran where
it's been memorized by millions well
just the way we know the timetable if he
comes says 9 3 times 3 is 75 we'll say
hold on a second mate is 3 times 375
it's free time cents
what is it three times four years is 9
so we correct them just the way we pray
and the man says something wrong what do
we do we correct them can we ever go
wrong if we have this principle hmm can
we ever go wrong with memorization if we
have the principle of we all know the
times table no matter who comes and says
three times 3,000 we say my friend
you've lost the floor is three times
three is nine we correct him would we
ever go wrong no now we have that with a
Quran which is this is the reason why so
today the only scripture that we have
compiled now what I'm saying to you is
this we fail the test in the Bible that
the verses have been added in and taken
out it's been it's happened with the
Quran we gave
time we gave you maybe five minutes you
didn't do it now I want to move on now
you need to understand this my friend
there we agreed on that we put the Quran
in the Bible to the test Bible failed
the first one the verses have been added
in when it comes to contradictions the
Word of God has not failed the Word of
God has always been remain in there it's
been there since the time of creation
who revealed John 7:53 then if it was in
the old manuscripts they tell you for
there was no John 70-53 yeah there
wasn't that's what she knew I did in
there if this one God who added in John
753 I don't know who had it you know
ok I'm not now as an honest person
because Jesus says seek the truth and
the truth of such a few yes what yes ok
as a person if you're truthful you don't
share in the context of the scripture
you have to look at the context of the
scripture what some insane mamita take
this course [ __ ] sure as reliable it has
to out we've stand and prove to me that
is from good but for so far it hasn't
done that so I can't rely on it you get
it if I give you a glass of water and
have Poor Bear poisoning I even a dream
plan
you won't unless you want to prove lack
in the Matthew it says if you have the
holy spirit you can drink poison apart
from that you wouldn't do it yeah now
can I show you how the contradiction in
the Bible can you open 2nd Samuel
chapter 24 verse 1 and again the anger
of the Lord was kindled against Israel
and he moved he moved David against them
to say go number Israel and Judah for
the kings the king said to Joab the
captain of the host and which was with
him go now through all the tribes of
Israel from Dan and even to Bathsheba
and number ye the people but I may know
the number of people ok they moved David
against them to say go and number Israel
and yessuh
well they took God said yeah yes God
said but if you go to a first Chronicles
off in chapter 2 verse 21 okay it says
Satan did ok first go this color goes ok
and Satan stood up against Israel and
provoked David to number Israel okay
now in first time you know who was it
was a god of Satan in 1st Samuel goes a
Lord was wrong which is God God yes
okay who inside to David in first minute
Satan their Satan okay is it God or
Satan it was Satan there yes it is here
but was it God it says got in some
avoiding suddenly yes and you know it's
also Satan there Oh God
no of course it's a word of the Lord and
the word of a word of those stands so
whatever what God said it is what the
Word of God is it basically what it's
saying what is you say well it says here
Satan and over in Samuel it says good
that's my problem do you get it that is
a clear-cut contradiction that's how me
saying your jacket is black and white at
the same time can you open John 3:16
please okay look the words the word
because I'm taking out or not know the
word well because it was okay because it
was the inscription okay okay let's arms
in Kings James Version the word begotten
is there but in your version most like
what version you have since King James
Oakley's King James you would have it in
here by Phi bring a New International
Version the word begotten is not anymore
hey why I don't know why okay now that
is a problem you get it
so is there any contradictions in this
book yes can you show me one please and
when we change the verse of the Koran ah
and when we change it verse of the Quran
in place of another and Allah knows best
that he sends down they the disbelievers
say o you O Muhammad are a Mufti forger
liar
nay most of them know not how was a
contradiction we have a verse in salt
and the hell describing that and when a
verse is saying verse is revelation
science evidence teachings and so forth
yeah when we change the change of the
Quran in a place of another so okay
what's that mean like alcohol I'll give
you the example of alcohol yeah don't
come to pray oh well you're drunk and
then you go abrogate and they said don't
get drunk at all yes Allah now saying
he's changing yes giving something
better thereof and that goes up back
again to surah bakra chapter 2 I on
physics about the law abrogation which
is abrogates the verse and takes it out
they're in and they're in and can I say
something
yes if this is from God and God do
whatever he likes to scripture of course
God can do I was okay okay yeah so if
this one good yeah okay now if that's
one but he's talking about for his own
like I said alcohol you can change and
say you know what first don't come near
Salah why do you drunk now you can
completely you shouldn't drink alcohol
that's application I'm asking for a
contradiction where he says blue here
and then he says the same thing is white
that's why I'm looking for we're talking
about the Quran huh wait where is the
contradiction don't okay I'll show you
this good to show me just say to me look
in surah Noor what is it
and surah mocha says white so I can see
okay you're right there's a
contradiction
I need a clear-cut contradiction well
you need to look for it for yourself my
friend but I don't know about the
fingers the virgin you to evidence on
the front so don't you see I gave me a
suitable ah
so Anissa you said God can change and I
said his God he can change of course I
can change if he says first don't drink
1 glass of alcohol yeah ok then the
application cycle you know that aqua is
not good for you anyway but but listen
that's the wisdom of God he's asking it
you get it there's no contradiction if I
say to you for example look you're
drinking alcohol cut it down drink once
once one cup of day you're gonna say ok
after that when I see your progress I'm
gonna say now you're ready to cut it
there's no contradiction
it's your progress and me helping you
with that ok yeah so I want a clear-cut
contradiction because we are three
criteria verses should not be added in
no contradiction the Quran has passed
both but the Bible is filled both this
book is saying if you have doubts that
it's not from God bring a chapter like
it come forward
where's the chapter well then you say
this one is chapter I look right in the
big one smallest well you said then
there's a to do two things firstly to
bring the chapter but it says bring
multiple chapters in the Quran so where
is it one chance on the part is the
current state bring one chapter was it
multiple chapters because when Allah
says bring multiple he saw that you guys
couldn't do that I said let me make it
easier for you bring one chapter so can
ask for that one chapter please because
we're making it easy for you first our
last head look bring mini now we say
look you can't and having a hard time if
it is the winner God what's a kind of is
the working with all of thing okay
before you start preaching it is what
it's before you start preaching before
you start preaching you need to bring
that chapter look this is this challenge
for you I'm asking you clearly can you
read this this one is John 753 your
Bible does enough ok
it can read it for me this is this is
can you read it for me please
why this is why why are you free no it's
not the vibe can I read it for you
can I read it for you okay so this is
this is this is John 753 the earliest
manuscripts and many other issue
witnesses do not have John 753 in 11
yeah all right who made this mistake God
or the man God is not God does not make
any mistake okay why where did this
verse come from them
what is this verse come from yeah I
don't know you put it up on your foot
this is your this is your Christian
scholars this is your this is normally
no I told you before okay can you show
me very very no no that's been around
the boy show me a verse show me a verse
where it says in the Quran this verse in
baqara has been added in nato
it's known on management just one just
one just one just one surah bakra show
me show me wait so a record show me the
foot 900 okay show me the footnote okay
can you show me the photo that says that
verse has been added in or taken up the
verse is here my friends can you show me
them okay can you show me the footnotes
and meaning it just like I have a
footnote in your Bible where it says
this verse has been added in I just gave
it to you already
no no no you read a verse to me we read
a verse to me it's like me reading John
7:53 I'm asking you where is the one not
anywhere no no no no this is your Bible
you're using Israeli to Bible Gateway
calm yes this is it look by book a wacom
yeah now show me a single verse in the
Quran where it says this verse is me not
is not a no that's what I asked for me
I'll just read it to you another you
read you read me a verse about the law
of average you read me a verse look what
is this is support no wonderful not for
a phono tells you something about the
verse yes it says it's been added in it
came in this time a single manage a
single footnote where it says that worse
has been I did not take another huh just
one just one I don't want to
I'm just I just want to say something we
had a challenge and the challenges it
was a clear-cut challenge if this
scripture is from God Almighty it should
have no verses added in no errors no
contradictions you did not find one of
these in the Quran and we showed you
free in the Bible
now now now you're seeing now you're
saying can I can I just do you mind okay
all right this is the upset okay your
claim in the world of the Bible is from
God the Quran is from man and I'm saying
this man did a better job than your God
because it has no errors no
contradictions and no verses I didn't
whereas the Bible it has verses I didn't
it has contradictions it has many errors
so how is it that the Prophet Muhammad
did a better job than your God
you